was it hard not to argue when they're
when you're starting a company and
there's creative differences i mean how
did you learn because that must have
been you had never in my life never i
was extremely shy i really wouldn't talk
to people i didn't want to talk to
people i didn't want to have
confrontation which is arguments
and um no and we might have differences
of opinion but i would never ever take a
strong you're wrong never you're wrong
almost never almost never i mean there's
some extreme cases maybe yeah i heard
something like you threatened to walk
from apple
something about the production of the
apple
two or three or four yeah they wanted to
tell the story phony story story came
about yes we had a shareholders meeting
the apple ii my apple ii was all mine
was all of the income of apple for the
first 10 years of the company
what gave apple the springboard to
become what it is now okay it was that
product was important it was bringing in
millions of dollars a month all the
revenues of the company we had we had
just introduced the macintosh we had a
shareholders meeting all you heard
macintosh mcintosh mackintosh mackinac
they didn't mention the apple ii once
okay and so after the shareholders
meeting i went back to the apple ii iii
building nice triangle building on 280
and uh the
the apple the great people that ran that
division and the engineers on the apple
ii side were just storming they were
just so mad they were they were talking
about ready to quit
because they've been so insulted by like
being treated like they were nothing
that's how jobs treated it the macintosh
is everything and met apple ii they're
bozos and
and they were threatening to quit they
don't have a voice that i have
so i called up john scully i kind of
blamed him i don't know what's coming
from jobs call up john scully and i just
read him you know the book from my
perspective and these are good people
and they're being forgotten and and
that's just wrong john john said well we
mentioned apple 2 twice i don't know
where it was it must have been some
little double listen
and i hung up on him he was our ceo i
hung up on him but i just did it so he'd
know how we were feeling
the others in in my division and after
and then the wall street journal called
and they got wind of this this um
disagreement or whatever and i said no
i'm leaving to start a new startup
company to build the first universal
remote control for tvs vcrs
laserdisc which nobody in america had
hardly um there was only one hi-fi that
had a remote control and i had it a bang
olufsen and i had a satellite dish that
built myself big huge dish there was no
satellite subscriptions yet
and so i had five controls how do you
introduce them to one so i started a
company and i went on blackboard and
showed the apple engineers in my
division what i was planning to do so
they know that i wasn't undercutting
apple or doing something apple would
want to do wrote me the nicest lever
kept me on the payroll even kept me as
an employee but the wall street journal
called and they said you know i told
them what i was upset about at the
shareholders meeting and they us they
wrote that that was why i was leaving
and i said no that's not why i'm leaving
i'm leaving to do this new project a new
startup
and they wrote it the other way and
steve jobs really believed that i was
you know against the company and and but
he didn't have enough the wherewithal to
see that i was still an employee
and it was really funny because after we
were building that remote control we had
the plastic pieces
and well we went to frog design to make
the plastics frog design was apple's big
design people that steve jobs liked a
lot and i said you do projects for other
companies yeah
so we hadn't designed some possible
remote control shapes and then i heard
the head of frog design talking to my
partner joannis on the phone
and the head of frog design told how
steve jobs came by on his bicycle one
day and and the head of frog design
herman esslinger or whatever his name
was showed him showed him the remote
control said look what we're doing for
your partner steve wozniak
and jobs threw it against the wall he
said put it in a box and ship it to me i
own everything you do
or apple owns everything you do
i listened and heard those words what
human being what decent human being
could ever ever do something that way
you know i would never bring up a kid to
be that way or encourage anyone else to
to be that kind of a person
wow
that was that was that's you know
you know you run into um i don't know
narcissism i'm in control of everything
was he always that way like because you
knew him when you guys when did you guys
first meet first of all
the world knows about two steve jobs
steve jobs one was ruthless a lot of
people did a lot of nasty things
but he was good to some people that were
important to him good engineers and
whatever he was actually good and never
did something like that directly to me
except a couple incidents i just
described one
um and then he went away and he came
back steve jobs too and he was a little
more refined
and i don't even know if that's true
because there were still some things
going on that were
very jobs just
somebody walks in an elevator and just
what they're wearing you're fired
still that would still happen so but i
knew steve jobs zero
for five years before apple we were
friends he'd come into town every so
often see my latest invention and turn
it into money for both of us
so that was uh we had a good
relationship and we'd played pranks we
played in the world we played pranks on
each other
we joked around with
the day i met him he was 16 years old
and had no albums
okay so i brought in my house i had
every bob dylan album and i let him read
the liner notes and the interviews with
bob dylan and then the lyrics to the
songs desolation row and songs like that
this became so important to us that his
words had like life meaning
and so we've we followed up people that
had dylan memorabilia we would drive
long distances to meet with them and and
then we would go to concerts and
everything dillon concerts that was a
big part of our life so but this is
before apple who you are
in life
gets formed it's called personality
your personality isn't going to change
ever
neither is mine it's yours
when your your personality settles down
between 18 and 23 years old college
years and that's who you are going to be
forever now steve jobs had always wanted
a path to be somebody important in the
world but he didn't have any academic
background he's living on communities
like with abs you know nothing finally
had me was about it
and uh and so he and he wanted the path
to be someone and now all of a sudden
with my apple ii
big money was willing to be put into it
and uh steve jobs is now founder of a
company he didn't have a title really
just founder of a company that had big
money this was how he was going to
spring into the world you had a company
you had to make a lot of money you had
to become one of those important people
and he started just talking like all
computer intelligence came from him
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
uh